cette convention précise des engagements
de la ville de saint brieuc dans
l'organisation de ces championnats de
france de voile une subvention de 170
francs
la mise en place d'un pc presse l'accès
aux réseaux numériques
mais pour la municipalité il s'agit
aussi de promouvoir le tourisme dans la
baie de saint brieuc et le département
nous devons nous avons la mer nous avons
un plan d'eau magnifique et vite à moins
de trois heures de paris
alors voilà ce que nous voulons faire
passer comme message à la population de
reste de la france les épreuves de
planche à voile se dérouleront en face
de la plage des rosaires 800 coureurs
attendus d'autres sites du département
accueilleront les catamarans dériveurs
420 et optimise les villes de perros
guirec binic pléneuf-val-andré 5 ha et
jugon les lacs se mobilisent ainsi pour
ces championnats
deux mille cinq cents concurrents vont
entrer en compétition pendant quinze
jours et 15 sont officielles
superviseront les différentes régates ce
soit sur des sites différents mais avec
un relais qui ne s'est jamais fait non
plus avec des moyens techniques
le réseau numérique nous pourront
diffuser toutes les informations
qu'elles soient d'ordre touristique
d'ordre d'animation où les résultats
concernant les coureurs au même moment
sur tous les sites
réunir toutes les disciplines de voile
dans un seul département c'est une
première si l'opération réussit le
comité départemental de voile envisage
de se porter candidat pour des
compétitions internationales